welcome back let's go to mom of two
jacqueline cooper who says she is for
the vaccine jacqueline you told me one
of your concerns is that you feel like
there is resistance to the vaccine in
the community meaning people who are
refusing to get themselves their
families and their children vaccinated
what's your main concern
my main concern is we look at people
in our society and our community and
we're judging them whether or not
they're being safe and that blows my
mind that we're taking
something as simple as humanity and
making it such a a huge
variant in our culture i mean
you look at me you wouldn't know that i
have a sister who has a child at home
with childhood cancer and she can't
leave the house because
of the you know coben what's going on
and she can't have him get vaccinated
because of his immune system and i have
to protect myself and my surroundings
because i do come in contact with her
and so i'm shamed by other moms and i'm
laughed at for wearing masks in public
but you wouldn't know that unless you
knew my situation and it's frustrating
and it's discouraging and it's
disheartening that people are so selfish
during this time and we have the ability
to build up this great herd immunity and
to to make these great strides to
protect those that are less likely to
overcome this disease and we're
selfishly just ignoring science
blatantly and i just can't get my mind
around it at what point did we stop
trusting the professionals and at what
point did we stop having
compassion for each other and empathy
and that that's what's really on my mind
lately
and thank you jacqueline um
joanne rude ruper is this something you
see about parents really being polarized
well i i can understand uh jacqueline's
point of view as far as having someone
in their family with cancer and
uh
you know compromised immune system and
that is a lot of concern with those
people who cannot get the vaccine or it
doesn't work as well because of their
immune system so you do have to do a
kind of cocooning around that person to
make sure that they don't get sick
and i you know children sometimes they
also
feel
anxious being out in the world they're
afraid that they might get sick from
covid so maybe having the vaccine would
actually make them feel better and more
confident about getting out and you know
going to activities going to a friend's
house
thank you and jacqueline tell me the
ages of your children
i have a three-year-old and a
nine-year-old and what is the status of
the nine-year-old as far as that covid19
vaccine
we just got home on a delayed trip last
night sorry for missing yesterday so we
have not had an opportunity to vaccinate
her yet but we have an appointment
scheduled for this week and she will
have her first dose okay thank you so
much for sharing that with us
we are going to now switch over to
father of six brian dawkins he tells me
he's not an anti-vaxxer but he's against
the covid19 vaccine for himself and his
children
brian what is your main concern what's
your question
well let me preface my comment first by
saying that i have nothing but respect
for people's decisions regarding masking
social distancing and whether or not
they get the shot i just believe that it
needs to be a personal decision not one
that's coerced
and i do have several areas of concern
but what's most alarming to me is the
fact that congress preemptively
indemnified the pharmaceutical
manufacturers against civil liability
if something goes wrong with the shot
they've actually been doing this since
1988 and another law was passed in 2005
to further protect
the drug makers
and what that does is it doesn't
protect the patient
so if i or my wife or my children decide
to get the shot
and then have a
adverse reaction
myocarditis or
down the road we find out that they're
all infertile because of something that
happened because of the drug
we have no legal reports we cannot sue
the drug makers and i'm going to out of
the government joanne ruper of the
southern nevada health district to
address that um joanne what would you
say about brian's concern
right so uh
for the you know i would i'm the local
health department and a healthcare
professional so i really can't say
anything about the legal
aspect of it but
there are a lot of good information on
the cdc website that talks about that
and how that that how did that come
about and how that process
is for those who may
experience adverse events thank you so
much and back to brian here brian could
you do me a favor and tell me the ages
of your children also a couple of
follow-ups here have any of them
contracted the covid19 vaccine and do
any of them want the vaccine
i'll try to remember your questions in
order
my children are 17 15 15
one's turning 13 tomorrow a 12 year old
and a nine-year-old
and no one in my household has
had the virus and no one in my household
has any interest
in getting the shot
and i would rather not wear the masks or
following the protocols although again
we're respectful of other people's
decisions when we're asked to do those
things we comply
but it's not something that anyone in my
household is interested in pursuing
brian are your kids attending school or
what's the situation
my wife and i educate our children at
home but our children are active in the
community
they're involved in several
social organizations and
they have
continued to be around their peers and
adults
for the last year and a half without any
adverse reactions
has any information that you've heard
here so far in this town hall
swayed you one way or the other do you
see yourself ever changing your mind
i'm open-minded i'm willing to change my
mind as facts present that would
encourage me toward that conclusion but
no nothing that's been said here is any
different than what we've been hearing
the last year and a half uh that we
should trust the experts and just go
with it and i realized that adverse side
effects from vaccines are rare but as
skyler pointed out earlier
so is death from coven
so we're weighing one slight risk
against another slight risk
and
when we choose to get the shot as i
previously stated there's no legal
recourse
while there are injury compensation
programs administered by the government
they have very low financial taps that
don't measure up to what a lawsuit would
result in and think if something was
done incorrectly so no nothing's been
presented that could change my mind
thank you brian i want to go back to dr
e could could you weigh in on sort of
brian's view here
well i again i'm on the medical side so
in terms of compensation and sort of the
recourse piece i am i'm no expert in
that but in terms of you know science
and the experts
i understand that this is a global
pandemic and things are continuing to
unfold before us and i love hearing that
he's open-minded because as evidence you
know comes forth and things change and
maybe the landscape changes he might
hear something that speaks to him and i
i believe he would do what he feels is
the best interest of his children which
is ultimately what every parent wants to
do thank you so much now coming up we'll
see if any parents on our panel change
their minds after this discussion we are
live local now